hey youtubers it's Charlie so this week
on orphan black we got to learn a whole
bunch about the original cloning
experiment it seemed like everyone was
changing allegiances and we get to see
some very pretty dirty sexy Rachel if
you're finding me for the first time I
typically do orphan black videos every
week I didn't do a video last week
though so there is no episode for video
be sure to subscribe to get everything
and if there's some questions you have
about that episode or anything else just
leave them in the comments so this
episode was filled with a bunch of WTF
moments that made me laugh a lot I'm not
really sure what you would call moments
like that
not exactly WTF funny but careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet here are my top 5 moments
number five Paul becomes Rachel's new
Daniel turns out that's a pretty
demanding job I love the power dynamic
in all of Rachel's relationships not
just the sexual ones it's like any room
she walks into she just dominates unless
she's with Sarah and then there's always
this weird vibe just because I think
rachel is a little bit afraid of her
maybe of Hellena too it did kind of seem
like Rachel was having fun trying to
take Sarah's toy you know toy being Paul
maybe that's just a sister thing but it
is fun to watch her be petty just
because she's always so hard to read I
also couldn't really tell what Paul's
motivations were in all this it seems
like he's going to the dark side and
rachel is just the emperor in all
fairness though if the emperor in Star
Wars
looked anything like Rachel there would
be a lot more people trying to join the
Sith including me number four
Paul plants the gun on Felix I loved how
this moment went from really sweet to
funny to scary so fast
Felix gets his crazy date night montage
with Colin and the one thing he promised
wouldn't happen totally happens in the
police burst and it's hilarious you know
just as Khan squeezes that entire tube
of lube out on his hand
the look on his face - was priceless
just like is he's squeezing that bottle
out just like what then just for a
minute
I actually really thought Rachel had
sent Paul to kill Felix but it's all
about blackmailing Sarah she hasn't
taken the bait yet so as of the end of
the episode Felix is still rotting in
prison you could really take any of
those moments from the sequences
favorites but the actors actually did
say that filming that gun scene was
really hard just because it was so
intense for those characters let me know
if you think that Paul really would kill
Felix or one of the other non clone
friends
I don't think Rachel would ask anyone to
kill any of the core clones though it
was kind of implied that he killed
someone for her in Taiwan and that
person might have been a clone it was
hard to tell what Rachel was thinking
whenever she was first telling him about
taking him to Taiwan I kind of thought
she was either taking him for security
or for sex or maybe both I really do
like the way that rachel is blurring
lines with Paul and especially the fact
that they invoke Daniel in their you
know special lovemaking scene number
three dr. leekie likes beer I'm so happy
with the way the allegiances are
changing leekie is not best buds with
clone club or anything but he is making
them a deal at the end of the day I
think he just wants to push his project
forward and he's willing to help Sara in
the clothes if it means he can recover
lost data there were so many bombs
dropped about that original cloning
project and all those Cosima leekie
scenes now they're searching for that
synthetic DNA inside the clones that's
keeping them alive my guess is they
won't be able to cure what's ever making
Cosima sick until they find Rachel's
father and whatever data he has left or
whatever he remembers
I'm also totally expecting leekie to
double cross clone Club again if he's
lying to Rachel to help Cosima then why
wouldn't he just turn around and lie -
Cosima at some point let me know if you
think that he'll keep helping clone club
after he gets what he wants because
that'll be the real test number two the
Creator is still alive one of the
creators that is but it looks like Swan
man Rachel's father is alive and hiding
out somewhere
Hellena is the world's best bloodhound
so if the pacing of the last couple of
episodes holds up they'll probably find
him in the next one or two episodes but
basically here's the situation they're
in especially with relation to Swan man
all the original data on the cloning
experiment in the genome that they
developed to grow the clones was lost in
the fire so they can't grow more clones
or fix any of the existing clones until
they get that information and right now
it looks like Swan man is the only one
who has that I'm wondering how mrs. s is
connected to him - she's in her 50s and
Swan man is supposed to be in his 70s so
maybe she was just like a lab tech
working in their office or an intern or
something like that or maybe she's
related to one of the original project
leader people I'm so happy that they're
giving us all this backstory on project
Leda though it's like they're developing
a prequel show on orphan black it'd be
like clone clubs set in the 70
maybe if orphan black ever goes off the
air they'll just do that show and my
number one moment
Sarah stops Hellena from killing Rachel
I actually thought this moment was more
intense than Felix with the gun
mostly because Sarah stepped in front of
the sniper rifle while she was trying to
talk to Lena down don't forget that was
all going down while Rachel was having
crazy sex with Paul I feel like she's
using weird sex to let her emotions out
because she never betrays any emotion on
her face whenever she's walking around
in real life Paul's like the new
racehorse she's thinking about buying so
she just inspects him like an animal
this was pretty epic as far as sex
scenes go and how amazing was Hellena
this week she was by far my favorite
clone in the episode I just can't get
pretty dirty sexy out of my mind and
don't forget about the crazy Rachel doll
she had who else laughed whenever Sarah
threatened leekie with Hellena at the
bar later I really do love the dynamic
between Helene and Sarah right now it's
like they had their own little clone
Club inside of clone club like plana
does acknowledge the other clones as C
straws but the only one she's bonded to
is Sarah just because they were born as
twins but now it's your turn let me know
below in the comments what was your
favorite moment and which of the sex
scenes did you think was the funniest
you know not like intentionally funny
but the sex scene that you laughed at
the most overall the episode was a solid
b-plus I always get really excited
whenever the writers flip a bunch of the
relationships on the show leekie helping
the clones Paul letting himself get
dominated by Rachel like I said favorite
clone this week though was Elena
Rachel was fascinating but this week
Hellena was like a black hole for my
attention just so strong I couldn't
think about anything else whenever she
was around it really is so easy to
forget that Tatiana maslany is playing
all these clones but I feel like you can
only fan over her so many times until
you all just accept it as something
that's always gonna be happening like
she's always gonna be amazing so we just
generally accepted his truth of all the
characters right now though I feel like
Felix and Paul are the weakest so like
at the bottom of the pile Felix gets
physically dominated you know mostly for
comedy but Paul is like a robot that
Sarah and Rachel are controlling right
now I think that he thinks he's doing
everything for the greater good but
really at the end of the day he has no
will of his own he's just an appendage
of Rachel right now an appendage you
know she likes to have sex with and
really
strange ways I'm really hoping though in
the next couple of episodes we get like
an extended Hellena rachael moment but
here are a couple really big plot points
from the episode that we need to
acknowledge so just so we don't forget
anything we have to talk about Gracie in
that torture closet she's not gonna walk
away from this season with all her
marbles the proletheans are just way too
crazy to let anyone stay saying more
importantly she's probably gonna end up
having to carry that creepy baby and as
nuts as she is how can you not feel bad
for her I mean she's just a little girl
Kira and Cal are totally adorable
together but she is just like operating
on a whole different level
it's like she's doing her own thing off
to the side that no one else is aware of
like she just keeps manifesting
supernatural qualities in really unusual
ways she's so self-aware that it's
unsettling like one of her cows making
jokes about socks she's scanning money
passports and guns and then there's
Cosima sickness she's been hiding from
the rest of the clones Sara understands
what's going on but with Allison and
Rehab it seems like clone Club is slowly
coming apart at the seams
I am so excited to find out what place
of screams is next week though that
sounds like a club that Stefan from SNL
would be really excited to go to so in
related news there is a new episode of
orphan black next week I'm gonna try and
do a video but I have to go out of town
for a wedding so be sure to subscribe to
get everything I'll be doing some bonus
videos but I'll try to keep everyone
updated on social right now click here
to watch my last orphan black video and
click here to learn all about the new
Grant Gustin flash TV show that's coming
this fall I'm really excited about it
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives
you